nevada's version of that groundhog
punxsutawney phil
well he's finally up and at him here
that we're talking about the desert
tortoise there he is mojave max he
finally woke up
from his long winter's nap known as
brewmation the reptilian form of
hibernation
11 34 yesterday morning and that's
important it was at the springs preserve
max almost set a record it is the fourth
time that he didn't wake up until
mid april not the latest though that was
back in 2012 it didn't get until the
17th
so we're waiting to find out which local
elementary school student guest
closest to the desert tortoise's actual
emergence time
that kid's going to win a laptop
computer and a pizza party for their
class
the mojave max education program has
been going on for more than 20 years and
john
sherry alex proud to be a part of it and
sherry we've had you out at some of
those school assemblies where we talk to
the kids about
the environment and teach them about the
desert it's very fun too and the kids
are always really excited to learn and
so it's a great program and of course uh
virtual
last year for the kiddos but yeah always
excited to hear who the winner is who
got so close to
guessing when uh when max might actually
show up a boy he was snoozing long and
hard this year nate you sure was now
one of the first kids ever to win the
contest some 20 years ago
is now a uh firefighter for los angeles
county i happen to know his folks who uh
we met through
little league taylor child is the young
man's name i think he's like 25 years
old
oh my gosh that is so cool yeah pretty
awesome
i love that yeah max uh max did snooze
quite a bit this year but
i don't think we can blame him no no
he's getting a little older now so he's
sleeping in a little bit more he's
earned the uh the right sherry
to just get a little extra hit this news
button a little more yeah